The tropical island of Bimini lies in the
northwest corner of the Bahamas off the coast
of Florida in the center of the island.
The Worldview two satellite captures this
image.
This is a really strange image because you
have this dark, green, lush landscape all
around, but you have this kind of like light
colored outline of what almost appears to be
a shark.
Why is there a giant.
Mound shaped.
Like a big shark rising.
Out of the swamp plant in the.
Bahamas? The waters here are among the most
shark infested on the planet.
There are at least 13 different species of
shark recorded here in teeming numbers drawn
to the islands from far and wide, from
cannibal hammerheads and aggressive, volatile
bull sharks to the lethal black tips and
tiger sharks.
Among the largest and second only to the
Great white for recorded attacks on humans.
The local Tiger Beach is one of the most
shark infested beaches in the world.
We do know that the Taino people who
inhabited many of these islands in this area
would have been very familiar with sharks.
Some individuals, if they were able to kill
or capture a shark, they would take the teeth
and make a necklace out of them as a way of
showing that they could conquer this animal
spirit.
It's not strange that the natives who once
lived here should fear and respect the shark.
The question is, did they worship it?
There's no question that ancient cultures
elevated or deified certain animals in their
cultures, creatures that they looked upon as
being powerful and and representing positive
or spiritual qualities that they admired.
Ancient Egyptians worshipped certain animals
as gods, Horus, the Hawk, Anubis, the jackal
neck bed, the vulture.
Their priests worshipped them with spells,
magic and sacrifice.
Did the ancient Taino people who for
centuries inhabited these islands do the
same? Most records of this.
Primitive people were lost when the Spanish
conquistadors slaughtered and enslaved them.
The only way to find out more is to examine
the site.
Explorer George Coronas has carried out
research into great white sharks.
He's come to the Bahamas to investigate the
image.
But before he heads out to Bimini Island, he
wants to know what the locals make of it.
He's been given a lead.
Local amateur historian Ashley Saunders.
I'm looking for.
Ashley. I'm Ashley Sanderson.
Oh, my name is George.
I understand that you're the historian.
I certainly am.
I've been documenting the history of Bimini
now for better than 20 years.
The Shark Mound.
Is it manmade or is it a natural occurring
thing?
The shark mind has been shaped by humans.
A human civilization.
Prehistoric.
Are there other sites in the area here in
Bimini that might suggest that there was an
ancient civilization that may have
worshipped the shark or may have lived here?
Well, in 15 feet of water, there's a
submerged set of stones that might be
pointing to ancient civilization.
A prehistoric civilization.
And. These stones have been baffling us on
this island for generations.
Interesting. Is there anything near the Shark
Mound that may be of significance?
Well, it seems as if the nose is pointing
towards the spring, the healing hold, the
healing. The fountain of youth.
Discovering the mythical fountain of youth
has long been the dream of explorers.
Local legends say that it became the
obsession of Spanish conquistador Juan Ponce
de Leon.
15 day ten.
He came here looking for the fountain of
youth that he heard about from the Indians
down in Puerto Rico.
So you think the healing hole may have been
the fountain of youth that Ponce de Leon was
looking for?
Might be.
Interesting.
Now George has a number of leads to follow.
Bimini Shark Mound lies hidden in the
northwest corner of the island on the edge of
the coastal shelf.
George must get there by boat.
On his way, he stops to investigate what
locals believe to be an ancient underwater
road.
We're anchored right above Bimini Road.
It's a series of huge stone blocks that run
the entire length of the coastline.
Some say that it's a remnant of a lost
ancient civilization that's now sunken under
the waves. I need to check it out for myself
and see what it looks like.
If there are beneath the waves, the ruins of
some ancient construction, it would suggest
these ancient inhabitants were equally
capable of building a shark mount.
But it's difficult to tell.
At first glance, it's not really obvious what
is going on.
See out of place.
Bahamas is known for its sandy bottoms, but
here we've got hundreds and hundreds of these
huge stone blocks lined all the way along
the coast here.
And we're talking about a series of what
appear to be manmade blocks laid out
relatively flat that extend for over half a
mile in a linear feature that absolutely
looks like it was constructed.
But in fact, I think it is a natural
feature.
And a lot of people say that Mother Nature
doesn't make 90 degree angles or straight
lines, and that's absolutely not true
geologically.
We see this all the time.
Either way, the undersea Bimini road looks
strange.
If it's natural, then it's unusual.
If it's manmade, then it's remarkable.
George pushes on towards the large shark
shape indicated in the satellite image, which
seems to be perched on the coastal shelf at
the edge of the Bahamas.
Yeah, this looks like.
A turn out right there.
But it's protected by a seemingly
impenetrable mangrove swamp.
It's a forbidding place, swarming with
bloodsucking insects, mangrove thickets like
barbed wire. The water's teeming with
sharks.
One thing to see something like this on a
satellite image is another thing entirely to
get to it on the ground. Obviously, it's not
so easy to get to this place.
So if it is indeed manmade, it certainly was
not made any time recently.
The water is shallow, but not too shallow for
sharks.
You see a lot of sharks around here.
Yeah. Yeah. What kind?
You got the lemon.
You have the nurse sharks?
Yep. The reef sharks.
The bull sharks. The tiger sharks.
Oh, we have a variety.
You see a baby shark?
Don't get excited either.
If I see a baby shark, don't get excited.
No. What if I see an adult shark?
Let it go faster.
Just let him go fast. This lane is only wide
enough for either me or the shark.
Open your leg and let him through.
I'm not opening my legs for any shark.
What is really strange is that the
environment is really inaccessible.
This whole swamp land is not a place where
you would normally find something like this.
The mangroves are around the water, but
there's a clearing right here.
You can sort of see if you look closely
where the mangroves basically stop.
So shark mount has got to be very close now.
I see.
Dry land. Yep.
After shark mouth.
Bingo.
George is immediately struck by the scale and
difficulty of this terrain.
This labyrinth of mangroves.
It's so confusing. I'm just trying to get my
bearings, comparing what I can see on the
ground with this old satellite image.
And it's not easy.
What I find interesting is building something
that you can't see must be really difficult.
I mean, these guys can't look at the things
from above like we can today.
Without a proper archaeological
investigation.
It's hard to tell more about the shark
mountain.
But there's one more lead for George to
follow.
Could the healing hole described by locals
be the same fountain of youth described to
conquistadors in the 16th century?
And does the nose of the Shark Mound
indicate its location?
We believe that this is the nose of the shark
pointing this way, I think.
So it looks like the body of the shark is
oriented more or less north, south, east,
west. Pretty close, actually.
It could be a coincidence. Or maybe someone
intended it to be that way.